ganó su mandato en el Congreso Nacional
africano en 2017 con la promesa de
limpiar la corrupción endémica pero tras
un escándalo propio civil ramafosa tuvo
que ganarse a los delegados de nuevo su
Victoria del domingo reafirmó su
posición como la figura más importante
del partido totalmente de Sudáfrica
para el camarada en quise su total es
para el camarada rama fosa
su total es 2476
[Aplausos]
en un discurso en la apertura de la
conferencia el viernes rama fosa repitió
La promesa de limpiar el partido
manchado de corrupción
a los responsables sean quienes sean
estén donde estén que se enfrenten al
poder de la ley
el presidente sudafricano evitó un
proceso de destitución a principio de
mes por un escándalo bautizado como
fahrenheit en el que se encontraron
millones de dólares escondidos en sofás
de su granja privada
rama fosa ha negado haber actuado mal
alegando que el dinero Era el pago por
la venta de búfalos ha superado una
fracción rival en el partido en torno al
expresidente Jake Uma que está siendo
investigado por corrupción y a su Aliado
suele en que también está manchado por
acusaciones de corrupción pero que
emergió como el único aspirante en
terrama fosa el escándalo ha minado aún
más la popularidad del CNA el partido
también se enfrenta a un descontento que
reciente por el desempleo la pobreza y
La escasez Crónica de energía a pesar de
presidir estos problemas ramafosa sigue
siendo visto como la mejor oportunidad
del CNA
el CNA lo necesita para sobrevivir en
2024 él necesita el CNA para la
protección porque está aislado pero
también sigue siendo relativamente
creíble Comparado con lo que hay dentro
partido
en la última década el CNA ha perdido el
control de ciudades claves en las
elecciones municipales el año pasado su
porcentaje de votos cayó por primera vez
por debajo de la mitad Pero sigue siendo
el partido más grande de Sudáfrica de
Cara a las elecciones generales del año
que viene